a new study reveals one out of eight
Americans is an alcoholic
however after Trump's comments on North
Korea yesterday it's now seven out of
eight that's why I'm drinking fire and
fury brand Scott I was weird yesterday
very weird yeah I had a lot to drink
after that and then did a show go back
and watch it you can tell
I really was drunk during last night's
show
I really thought it was the last show so
I was hammered the whole time fly what I
don't even know who I was talking to
last night
Wow
today President Trump tweeted quote
there will never be a time that we are
not the most powerful nation in the
world now Trump would have tweeted more
but just then I've Anka came in with his
juice box
thank you new report just came out it
claims that the Florida coastline is
rising six times faster than the rest of
the world yeah
Florian's Floridians are calling this
alarming everyone else is calling it not
fast enough
[Applause]
is that what's bringing the country
together that we don't like Florida is
that they like here put anyone here from
Florida oh hey hi sorry about that
good luck with that waterfront property
you own Wendy's
I got some good news for you Wendy's is
introducing a bacon burger that get this
comes with bacon mayonnaise and bacon
jam that's true story yeah spokesperson
for Wendy said and if that doesn't work
we'll just stab our customers in the
heart
with a bacon tagger in New York City a
sex toy company is going to allow women
to try out vibrators at a pop-up shop
well technically it's more of a pop in
shop
[Applause]
thank you yes thank you yes I went to
college thank you yeah hey get this
today is Smokey Bear 73rd birthday yeah
you can tell Smokies getting older
because now his motto is just let it
burn I'm watching Judge Judy okay no
what you did was fine that's good that
was plenty for that one a study just
came out I got I mentioned this a study
came out in front that the perfect time
to have sex the perfect time of day to
have sex is 7:30 in the morning yeah
yeah it is a perfect time because you
can have sex finish and then leave for
work at 7:30 to
right my motto is ladies I don't waste
your time yeah they've got things to do
right that was tough they like that it
loves that mom yeah she won't talk to me
[Laughter]
you